remember Pebble watches the pioneer of
smartwatches with a few of the biggest
Kickstarter campaigns totaling up over
40 million dollars
they're classic smartwatches dominated
the arena for several years but in just
a short year they were from market
leader to try and sell themselves so
what happened
make her stick around till the end to
find out welcome to Horace Harvick peple
got off to a great start 2012 with the
biggest Kickstarter campaign of all time
raising over ten point two million
dollars they entered his scene with
confidence and it was pretty deep
wallets the original pebble launched in
2013 and it was welcomed with some great
reviews this is really the first attempt
at a modern SmartWatch and that will
prove it there was a lot of interest
from wearable technology and gadgets the
first Pebble watch was pretty
rudimentary it would give you things
such as notifications text alerts
calendars and of course the time it was
capable of running some light apps such
as ESPN and Evernote soon enough the
pebble time came out and with this watch
pebble took a completely new approach
onto operating system this watch had an
even bigger kick starter with the
biggest kick star of all time to this
date of over 20 point 3 million dollars
the slogan was awesome software no
compromises
but even right here in very early stages
there were some signs of the company
heading in the wrong direction the
biggest red flag was the fact that they
had to return to Kickstarter Norwich
raised more money why were they not able
to get money from private investments
for what issue did these top-level
investors see in this company despite
these early signs of a big looming issue
that will completely ignore these signs
and continued moving forward and soon
enough there was an even bigger issue
the most anticipated watched from the
biggest tech company of the world Apple
came out in 2015 but pebble blatantly
ignored this release and their quote
unfazed by their lease they did not
think that this would cut into any of
their sales and I actually thought it
would improve their sales and they were
initially right there was more interest
in the Pebble watches as a
alternative to apple watch and a lot of
people even prefer Pebble watches due to
their simplicity your fellow really
started market right now I made a clear
purpose for themselves it probably
couldn't survive a disaster but
unfortunately they didn't do that
and you have to keep in mind that Apple
is a lifestyle brand while some people
did prefer the Pebble watch for
simplicity most people prefer the Apple
watch pebble was simply the cheaper
alternative and that's why many people
turn to it but Apple watch is actually
the preferred product it's like Toyota
in the car market and one really exactly
wants a Toyota Camry but it makes the
most sense to buy people definitely
prefer other manufacturers like Mercedes
Benz and Audi or BMW but that didn't
stop Toyota from creating a Camry that
is the best-selling sedan in all of
America for several years now it's
because they had a clear purpose that
drove all of themselves they made
reliable affordable family vehicles and
that clarity is what pebble was lacking
to make matters even worse pebble was
fighting against social views Apple
watch was that classy Fitness watch
while pebble was the geeky watch and
eventually sales started to shrink for
pebble and an insider stated that Apple
simply took up all of the auction that
was available
they clearly underestimated Apple but a
very strong brand name and decades of
product building knowledge further
issues arose as they had difficulty
paying their suppliers in Taiwan
throughout 2015 pebble had several
payment issues and he had several
outstanding notices whenever suppliers
would call for payments pebble who
wouldn't even reply in several cases
this is a very unprofessional of pebble
and shows how bad their management was
and this really hurts your reputation as
well these payments were still unpaid
even a year later when Fitbit entered
into acquisition talks to pebble the
issues that pebble had to deal with
simply compelling on top of each other
and they simply kept ignoring all of
them to make matters even worse there's
favoritism within the supply team they
preferred want a computer to compile
electronics and this really led to
battery
relations with their suppliers and as a
result they once again had to return to
Kickstarter to raise money for their new
products while they did extremely well
external once again these funds are
simply not sufficient to develop
products there are on Harvard corporate
magnets like Apple from here on out the
company really started to fall apart and
then soon enough Black Friday and Cyber
Monday of 2015 roll around and the cells
are actually lower in the previous year
this was absolutely terrible news for
the company they weren't even able to
surpass their own previous sales this is
when they've finally realized that the
company was going the wrong direction
and something had to be done very
quickly they finally started talk about
making change to company but by this
point it was already too late in March
of 2016
they had to lay up 25% of her staff
furthermore they started to compile
sales data and workers and the public
started to speculate that pebble was
trying to sell themselves the rumors and
theories were confirmed ran Erik
admitted to trying to sell the company
but unfortunately the deal failed he was
trying to close the deal with Intel for
70 million dollars but the Intel CEO
just felt that something was wrong with
the company and was not comfortable
closing the deal at this point there
were the complete recovery and they're
trying to former deal with the water
giant citizen they started to
collaborate with citizen in an effort to
create the time round they were trying
to develop their first circular watch
but there was clearly issues with the
collaboration citizen had a pretty long
developing times usually lasting over a
year and the designs were chunky and big
as a result pebble end up selling on one
of their own designs and ended up paying
$2,000 to citizen for their work rumors
started floating around that pebble paid
this in this money with knowledge of a
potential deal apparently citizen was
considering a 740 million dollar
acquisition of
which supports a billion dollars in over
ten times what the Intel CEO thought
that was worth but clearly this still
never went through and citizen claims
that these are false rumors that are
passed on to TechCrunch and that they
were never even considering buying the
company pebble actually offered their
employees two options they can cut
losses and leave and receive a severance
package or they can keep their shares
and stay and they're eventually their
shares be doubled some took the buyout
offer but most still had some last hope
for the pebble time - and a pebble core
which we thought would reinvigorate
sales these two products were on fact
for launch at the beginning of 2017
and even a week before the fit the
discussion started they were visiting
and manufacturing plants Asia for these
two products but as you admit yeah
trouble raising money private equity
funds and investment groups were simply
not interested in investing in pebble
they were simply out of time and money
as banks start as colander loans and
they were unconvinced that peddle would
be able to raise funding or sell enough
products to make up for the loan
it was the end of the line Erik knew
that it was all but over and one
honorable thing that he did was that he
wanted a buyer who would respect the
kickstart consumers Fitbit was the only
buyer who is willing to abide by these
guidelines it was thought that Fitbit
was going to acquire all or most of
pebble including all of her staff but as
discussions progressed it was clear that
Fitbit was really only interested in the
software side of pebble and not the
hardware so this was mainly because
they've been had their only issues to
deal with their stock price is almost up
to 50 at their very peak and now it was
less than ten dollars a share
I'm not even sure why they decide to are
a part of pebble especially in this
condition but in the end they did
acquire the softer side of ello
but unfortunately the hardware team
wasn't elected and most of them were
sent home with severance packages and
CEO Eric went over to work at the
startup incubator Y Combinator and at
this point it was all over
throughout this whole disaster from
beginning to end there's one underlying
issue that persisted throughout the
whole time which was terrible management
they had a huge tendency to just simply
a no problem instead of dealing with
them and solving them from failing to
attract investors to not paying
suppliers to ignoring competition all of
these issues were faced with ignorance
instead of care they didn't think why
investors thought twice before investing
a company that was clearly so loved by
the public they didn't think about how
to pay suppliers on time and they didn't
think about how they would convey a
clear purpose to the public when the
biggest company in the world was coming
to compete with them while their ideas
and concepts were great these issues
play the company and were probably
apparent to potential investors
they were almost overconfident that they
were the pioneers and all the costume we
couldn't stay with them despite rank
competition and the biggest company in
the world they clearly did look at the
several companies are much bigger than
them and then went to dust like Compaq
AOL Sears Kmart and Toys R Us in the end
pepper really was a great company I
started with good intentions and amazing
idea an extraordinary welcoming support
but all of this pay lovin became
meaningless in the face of bad
management and looming competition Peppo
could still be around as a great cheap
alternative attending to the masses but
unfortunately it never really made their
purpose clear and eventually consumers
simply forgot and moved on this is truly
a sad ending to a spectacular start but
that's all I have for you guys on the
decline of pebble babies comment down
below what company you would like me to
cover next also if you guys like to view
the message of life and consider
subscribing me flexi
just like this one by Joe then honey
aren't you guys on that